Before talking about conditional weight variables, I want to make a
distinction between mutual exclusion and
synchronization. Mutual exclusion, as we
have seen, is about preventing two threads from accessing a
resource, often a piece of memory, at the same time
regardless of exactly where they are in their execution. For
example, if Thread 1 is accessing this memory, then the
lock should block Thread 2 from accessing it or vice
versa. If Thread 2 is accessing the piece of memory then
the lock should block Thread 1 from accessing it. Synchronization,
by contrast, is about controlling where the threads are in
the flow of their executions. For instance, it might be
important that Thread 1 completes some task A before Thread 2
can start task B. In effect, we want the message
that A happened to get sent to thread B. Mutual exclusion
and synchronization are related. But it is important as a
program to know which of these goals you are after so
that you can use the right constructs.